i think it was i was in Cape Town I felt
like I'd failed in some kind of terminal
way the filmmaking which is silly to say
because I'm so young but I just I got
into a dead end and so I think in a way
the writing was an escape mechanism
initially and I wanted a creative outlet
and and the kind of turning inward mists
of fiction writing and it being so
solitary and and disengaging in a way
from the realities of South Africa and
just seemed like a very appealing and
but i do think always a way of avoiding
you know that issue in a way and i need
to find ways to to reengage that they go
outside of the writing because that can
then become endlessly you know
self-indulgent and if you if you don't
force yourself to kind of go out into
the Walden and and be accountable for
these relationships you have with
without a clue
well again I think it's no accident then
that this first novel that I've written
is not set any way geographically
specific so there's absolutely no
cultural markers and and that was a
conscious decision not to set it in
South Africa because I felt that the the
politics of writing and representation
was still too too complicated for me to
feel like I had any right to represent
south africa in any way so that was a
useful so it's in the form of a fable
and I think that non specific form kind
of allowed me to to create characters
who you are meant to identify with that
are actually at a haptic levada sort of
bodily level where you identify with
them the kind of bodily rituals of ali
processes that you know kind of are
repeated throughout the novel but if
they're not they're not really
characters from a you know specific
geographical or national setting so in a
way that's a way of dealing also with
the power
you